correspondent steve harrigan is in the
capital city tonight
u.s striker vehicles are moving into
romania part of the 3 000 troops already
deployed by the body administration to
strengthen nato's eastern flank
this as u.s weapons pour into ukraine
including more javelin anti-tank
missiles
a shoulder-mounted portable fire and
forget system that could help the odds
if one thousand russian tanks cross the
border new satellite images show more
russian troops vehicles and tents being
set up along ukraine's northern and
southern borders russia wants nato to
withdraw forces from eastern europe
demanding promises that ukraine and
other nations along its border will not
be allowed to join nato the west wants
russia to pull its forces back from
ukraine's border the focus on a possible
war is less intense for many who could
soon be in its path
i feel like people are spreading panic
saying that everything is bad and you
have to leave the country actually i
think things are getting back to normal
keeves skateboarders are also unalarmed
i don't watch the news very much but my
grandparents do and they tell me what's
going on i hope everything will be fine
russia's massive military exercises are
scheduled to end february 20th
the state department is already calling
americans in ukraine asking if they have
travel arrangements telling them they
should leave within the next 24 to 48
hours rhett
steve harrigan in kiev steve thanks how
those americans get out is up to them